you like Chinese takeout take me out big
boy
is really good
welcome back to a very uh I would say a
crucial and helpful episode of careful
boys oh wow today we have all the boys
with us oh the boys are backing down
easy easy we don't get a takedown
Steve's been gone in Indonesia's selling
cars I don't think that's true I don't
remember though I actually think Anthony
is doing that can we just not deflect so
here's um when you did that Anthony was
the was that guy there
that guy is this your backup dancer in
color yeah featured in the movie nope
there before I move on is there any
truth to that bit you were selling cars
we have to just move on you have to tell
us in Burma I think I heard it was a car
wash opening
Car Wash and Burma it's for cash
laundering
from my sources for money laundering
okay got it all right so
I came to this question and I thought it
would be great to ask you guys because I
saw a comment in uh one of our things
and it was a guy that was being very
nice and he was like oh I think he's a
gay dude he was talking about how he
loves Asians and then a couple people
started coming down on him and they were
like don't fetishize Asians like you
shouldn't say you love Asians and the
dude was like being really respectful
and cool and I was like what the [__] is
this and then so I thought the question
is what actually qualifies as Asian
fetishization you're infatuated with
small dicks hey dude the shortest video
we've ever shot amazing
oh what the [__] is fertilization
between like
ethnic fetishization and then being like
I like blondes and you're fetishizing
the blonde or like if you just like
things I think like I like titties I
like sedans I like ass oh what do you
have against trucks or whatever or like
I like Chihuahuas like what do you have
just a good way to some people just get
part of that right it's like are you
fetishizing pugs why'd you say it that
way can we just I'm just gonna be
fantasizing so like at least some people
go all the way down and slum it all the
way down and get poked where my mind
puts it and this is like my personal
definition I think it's when your views
about a certain culture supersede how a
person actually is oh that's a good
definition you're like oh I love Asians
so oh you guys are all like cute and
have no body here and you act like this
and that but what if you haven't even
met the dude and he's just not like that
then you feel because Japanese guys are
hairy right or you feel disappointed
because you're like oh you're not the
mental picture of what I thought Asians
would be and why I thought you'd be more
docile yeah exactly
obedient as a woman good at math yeah
yeah okay
fetishization
just tip you know how to do so
fetishization can be thought of as the
act of making someone an object of sex
or sexual desire based on some aspect of
their identity
some people like oh I like the librarian
because they look like this right if
glasses are cute don't guys just
fetishize everyone then I think well
that's what I was thinking like that's
just everyone's horny versus that
fetishization if a chick's at the back
of her skull looks like my foot could go
on it easily yeah I'm really into it I
thought that was more of a neck thing oh
it kind of hey but if they have boot
marks already like if they have boot
marks already do feel turned off by that
I think you're used yeah it's been
conquered or if Nikki comes home with
boot marks in the back of her head and
they don't match my shoes and I checked
then I'm like
you were cheating on me huh
I do agree with boot I think their
definitions probably act like the most
accurate I've heard is like you're you
have a expectation and a like idea of
what they are because you're like oh you
Asian mystical docile beings and then
you get what yeah yeah exactly exactly
and then and then there that's not even
what it's like a regular person that
also isn't that like just called a type
like some people only like this so if
you look at the whole past roster it's
always been that and obviously they're
all individuals right like they're all
one person might be an angry person one
person might be shy or whatever but they
have that type and that's just what they
like like what's wrong with it or if
somebody else who's not that type has a
problem with it isn't that just an
insecurity exactly that's that's why I
think I don't really think there's a
problem with this until you reach the
point where you express a disappointment
about it can I ask this
are hot people complaining about this
I don't have people complaining at all
this is why we need Steve on the streets
you know what I'm saying the definition
is is like broad enough where people can
add their own interpretation and be like
oh well and as soon as race is involved
I think people get super weird like I
think it's like cultural appropriation
right yeah because I feel like it
probably had some Merit to it when it
was created by an academic and then when
a when a simpleton like hears the term
like that one kid that was like my my
culture is not a costume it's not a prom
dress right that's not the point or
there was like a um like a Taiko like a
Japanese drum expert who happens to be
white but he moved to Japan for that
discipline studied it for over [__]
20 30 Years celebrated by Japanese
people but all this person saw she saw
like as a white guy playing Japanese
drums and said your cultural
appropriating that's fantasization the
simplification of like the stupid
activists like I feel like they [__] it
up I think they do yeah look they're all
annoyed so because they dude how about
this too it's not ingrained in them it's
not something that like they really were
raised to know and [__] it's something
they just read about and now they're
pissed because they just read it that's
true yeah and that's the other weird
thing about it it's like tourism it's
like [__] um anger tourism yeah how
about this example there's there's a
really popular one that gets brought up
a lot and it's usually from Asian girls
on dating sites okay and they'll post
the conversations they have with guys
and they hate when a guy says oh just
what I wanted an Asian oh I love Asians
Asian girls are so hot Asians that
already qualifies to them as oh that's
fetishization I don't want to date this
guy then [__] don't date him dude
that's just called bad game it's a bad
game it's a bad game it's true I was
always in the Mexican chicks growing up
right I thought I was I was like dude
I'm gonna marry Mexican check all this
[__] well I didn't go into Mex up to
Mexico I like Mexican chicks I like
Mexican chicks yeah that's weird yeah
there's your DM I'm like I love tequila
this guy's mind he thinks he's [__]
hitting a grand slam do you think that's
where the anger comes from it comes from
being on the receiving end of like
something else but that something else
happens so commonly that it's easier to
call it like this is fantasization
because like I know it's a problem and I
know people feel uncomfortable about it
right but then when I look at the
problem like
definition I'm like that's just called
you like something how about this yeah
broad Strokes right big examples to
underline points if you watch um one of
our favorite shows 90 Day Fiance that's
better suggestion that is because those
guys will go to like a European country
I'm sorry they go to an Asian country
that's weird or they go to a um Eastern
European European country yeah and they
prey on these chicks and I think that's
fetishization because they're coming in
with a stereotypical Viewpoint to try to
like throw a net in the water and come
out with a wife they have a name for it
they call it passport Bros but is there
a mutual earning on the other side
though yeah clearly there's an economic
disadvantage that but that's what I'm
saying though leveraging that it's
mutually beneficial is that like a
negative fetishism because like fetish
but is this person upping that person's
economic level yeah yeah economic level
yeah they might be yeah that might be
their type and it's like oh you're
fetishizing or whatever but it's like if
that person also has a mutual benefactor
you know what I mean yeah like mail
order brides yeah it's like I don't know
if it's gummy no yeah
because there are there are interracial
marriages and it's not scummy no and
it's like it's it's kind of romantic
sometimes I do think I do think
articulation articulation is an
important part about it that like is
often overlooked right because there's
like there's like the I like Asian
people right and that's like maybe a
type but if it's like a I only like
Asian people then you're
using your articulation to also like
almost denounce anything outside of it
but I also think that's okay too I like
blondes with big tits right and then
it's like well you're not a blonde with
big tits sorry I'm not into you know I
mean that sometimes that just happens
because there's chicks that are like I
only like guys that are taller than me
I'm like cool that's that's okay I knew
a Jewish guy that only dates black that
only dated black girls and you married
one yeah like that's just type when
somebody expresses an opinion like that
it's it's their loss if they're missing
out on other [__] exactly I find it
weird to say that he can't feel that way
yeah yeah that's [__] weird no the
guy who likes blondes with big tits he's
gonna miss out he will because I thought
I was in the Mexican chicks and I
married a [__] Filipino chick so what
do I know but don't you guys
don't assault like I don't know I feel
like guys are wired to have different
phases right so it's like you have
phases where you're like really into
like maybe the ABG type or like that
this type of Asian girl and then you're
really like oh you know what now I'm
really into like latinas or like
whatever and then it's like don't you
just go in and out of different phases
of what's the most attractive in your
mind you know I think the the issue is
though is like when someone talks about
it too much that's when you go okay dude
that's a little [__] weird if that's
all you talk about and that's all the
things that it's like on your mind then
it's a little like all right well also
to bring it back to your original
question and topic like today's video is
brought to you by honey love summer is
here and when I am walking around a very
hot neighborhood I see Hannah always
fiddling around with their luscious
boobies inside of her very uncomfortable
bra and I was like honey what's going on
and she's like oh my goodness this thing
is itchy it's sweaty it's Pokey I don't
know what to do well thank goodness I am
a bra connoisseur if I may I have a
suggestion honey love has bras that are
so soft it feels like second skin you'll
immediately feel and see the difference
and I already do for a more lounged
relaxed bra I recommend the V bra it
supports like a traditional bra but
without the uncomfortable underwire and
you can pair your V bra with some
leggings you could use it for every day
I mean like working out beating up some
dude that was creeping on you even at
your wedding when you're about to say no
at the altar or just hanging out at the
pet store so treat yourself to the best
shapewear on the market and save 20 off
at honeylove.com
OTR use our exclusive link to get 20 off
honeylove.com
OTR cinched snatched and lifted it's hot
girl season thanks to Honey Love
fetishizing Asian dudes like isn't that
like lower on the [__] list like mind
if it's Anthony Lee I heard I heard in
the gay community it's pretty popular
yeah yeah it was it because we're docile
no because we're good little geishas no
but there is that question of like is it
offensive for a dude to say I like Asian
women because they are docile you
know that's weird it's weird it's too
specific it's too generic you don't know
that they're all docile with the [__]
you talking about that's a massive
overages I've watched a [__] movie or
a video of something and yeah they're
playing to attack they're playing to
your good obedient little [__] that's
a great movie by the way but that's the
part that I think could be harmful in
the sense that if you have a guy that
really believes that hey you're an Asian
woman you're supposed to listen to me
that's scary that's scary that's just
mental something that's mental but then
again that's just a bad partner
generally yeah I don't really think
that's a rooted but there's so many guys
like that where they meet one person
they go that's how all of these guys are
yeah so it gets scary so I get I get
white people by the way this is probably
a good thing that people are looking for
people who are fetishizing things just
as a self-defense mechanism probably a
good thing it's a hello red flag though
I'd rather have women like say that and
go this fucker's weird versus oh you
like Asian you like Chinese takeout take
me out big boy you know what I mean like
it's definitely a way better sentence
it's really good yeah because like if
you were talking to a girl and she was
like oh my God I love Filipino dudes
like and she won't shut the [__] up
about anything Filipino wouldn't you be
like this is weird this is just odd but
I would I would say whether it's race or
just surface traits right like it gets
old like you're just like oh I like big
titties big titty big titties right and
then like how long can you have oh yeah
baby a long time
most of your life really probably longer
than flat but how long can a human live
I had an ex that when I met her when we
when we just met like cold met each
other she would straight up always say
like oh I [__] love Asian she was
like white from Florida yeah she would
just always [__] say [__] love
Asians I want an Asian baby if we don't
work out just still get me pregnant I
just want an Asian baby like she would
keep her that [__] that people normally
don't last time don't like it sounds hot
though it's kind of hot yeah she sounds
kind of [__] up in a way that I like
sexually yeah which is the definition of
fetishization thank you but you can't
say the words non-profit the white guy
it was like she doesn't really have I'm
a fetishist she's just [__] I don't
know she just really liked Asians at
that phase yeah but then who might I
tell her don't say that no it's like
that's how you feel that's how you feel
if I'm within that [__] that that
shotgun [__] blast that's great it's
okay do you think the the line the line
that gets crossed between sexual
preference to fetishizing is when you
fill in the blanks of expected
personality traits yeah because
fetishization I mean to me sexual
preference is just physical it's like a
a a shape of a butt or like legs right
or whatever but then I don't put a
definition of emotion behind that like
that's the problem you know girls with
long legs are [__] dumb
we should do that
but then once you once you
well I think once you put it I like this
new campaign you're leading but once you
put like a trait behind a physical
attribute that's when you it's like like
oh you know like [__] you know small
titted girls they suck dick so hard and
they listen to everything you say well I
will say and I have said this previously
I I think fat chicks give the best head
ever
but but they also have an ability to
lose weight and that can and it makes
them suck it makes them suck harder
that's weird but you're right is that
weird it is the thing where it gets in
the way of like if you're holding
another person accountable for how you
think their race should be yeah then
that's [__] weird oh yeah if you're
like hey what happened yeah how come
you're not a little freak I thought
you're supposed to have bad credit I
don't want your Finance is so good what
this guy said to me I thought Asians
were supposed to be good at math and he
said that to me as an insult and I hurt
my feelings you should have been like
you're right but you haven't been to
Hawaii yet yeah I was like how does he
know you're not good at math what
happened it was an exchange I was even
talking to you no yeah yeah
why are you talking to him was it
because you were actually bad at math no
I was I was working at Giant rockets and
he he came in he came into the customer
bought a soda and then I was ringing him
up and then he had an issue with how
much change I gave him I gave him more
change doesn't the cashier
do the math for you sir he [__] it up
he [__] it up you know what I never
understood you gave him more change but
he [__] it up he [__] it up sounds
like you [__] up I just said just take
the cash dude the thing that I don't
understand is if someone's beneath you
why do you get offended by their
stupidity so like if someone were to DM
me and they said something like pretty
stupid or they had weird stereotypes
like for me I'd feel embarrassed if that
got to me and I let their level make me
feel offended well just because we're
all created equal so they're not really
beneath you you're also insecure and
defensive as soon
as soon as I see that kind of stupidity
in someone I'm like oh I'm superior to
you you don't want to try to change them
no I feel like they're they're too
stupid they wouldn't be able to
understand yeah you don't want to save
them you need to save them but like is
it fetishization for example you married
Hannah she's a Brit right a limey right
a dirty limey and one of my favorite
stories about that is you telling me the
first time that you had sex with her
when you like pushed inside of her you
said now say it and then she said
yeah you're you're fetishizing is that
was that fetishization or like you know
what is it it's britishization okay okay
it's because they colonized the world
that it's okay that you were colonizing
her is that what it is maybe but is it
even exchange is this is fetishization
National or is it ethnic that's the
thing it's hard to say it's all the
above it's a good example of something
that just gets bandwagonally said a lot
I think because it's so it's such an
easy way to like feel like you netted
somebody yeah and I think that's I think
the the fear of fetishization gives
birth to generalization where you see a
white guy with an Asian chicken you go
oh you're one of those yeah like if
someone looked at you and was like oh so
you only like Asians but they don't even
know you're [__] dating his mind I
thought she's Mexican I get [__] up
I got huevos Ranch Herald what happened
does that happen to women like because I
haven't seen that happen to girls like
like for example like you know you're
with smack you know I'm with Hannah but
like they don't get
from other women why are you not with
your kind or whatever yeah I mean like
it's it's not the other one should
happen more often like the good old days
yeah I wish it would no I don't think it
does I don't think it happens that much
I mean like Yeah from Women to Women it
seems like it guys thoroughly enjoy
dancing with black girls at the club
more than any other
maybe you like dancing with black queens
I don't know that maybe is that a is
that an ethnic thing or is that like a
cultural well it depends on why you
understand Rhythm and the culture that I
like so they just dance they're they
better dance better dancers so you tell
me I am not indirectly or directly I
definitely agree in the sense that I
think Black Culture is better at Social
dancing at a level of like it's just in
their family and how they do [__] so
it's not like us we have to learn at a
late stage how to interact in a dance
floor like [__] robots you know
they're raised with the comfortability
the same way Latin families are with
like [__] you know getting down you
just see people do it's like you you get
it I do think we're getting closer and
closer but like let's say if I replace a
few words if it's gonna feel weird like
I said articulation is important so say
I'm a police officer say that I'm scared
already this is a police officer I like
to arrest black people more than others
is that weird it's like why are we like
why is it like that it's like once
dancing and that's okay but the other
one it's kind of like the same thing
it's like what it's a good point why'd
you have Anthony say he's a police
officer and then you said the [__] up
thing no I'm trying to have
but I'm trying to get him to say the
same Dynamic I have an editor's note to
cut what BART said Anthony
makes it seem like he said
that I like to arrest black people more
than others like what like why is like
you know I don't know it's weird
hey but that's the that's the dicey part
though even what you said even if the
compliment could still be and some
people will take it some people oh
you're a fetishizer maybe that's the
exact point that this guy that we're
even talking about this gay dudes in the
comments is talking about how he likes
something but out of context is taken
out of his neck maybe Asian guys give
the best blow jobs but he doesn't want
to say it's true that's true because
when I heard that comment I'm like
that's perfectly fine you're entitled to
your own opinions yeah but also keep it
to yourself huh
because as soon as you go on the
internet and tell everybody then it
gives the door for everyone I don't know
if I've learned anything from this video
that's the problem with over sharing
yeah don't be an overshare okay to
[__] open up and oh I love Asian
[__] I can't wait to [__] a real
Asian [__]
sometimes you can't speak your truth too
loud keep it in bro if you speak your
truth too loud and someone finds out
that oh I love cheeky dicks yeah and
then you're like whoa dude that's weird
and then you can't get mad at what you
said was interpreted as weird also just
keep it inside and then in your head you
can be like oh my God I can't believe
I'm [__] real Asian domicile [__]
oh yeah I'm good at colonize this
[__] thing I'm gonna colonize it so
good but you keep it on it is true you
just keep it to yourself and then when
she says what are you thinking about you
go I'm thinking about I have a [__]
dinosaur
thinking about a T-Rex [__] a
Triceratops the part the part that I
don't like about this is the after
effect of him earnestly saying I like
Asian guys and then a bunch of [__]
Asian people get mad at him for that and
now he goes you know what I don't think
I like Asians
I don't like that Asians get mad that's
a new stereotype agents get mad at me
all the time [__] Asians get mad just
even mentioning Asians yeah yeah yeah
like I don't like that yeah no that's
lame
foreign